modern societies are pretty much in
agreement on this score
having children is one of the most
meaningful and delightful moves
that anyone can make couples who don't
for whatever reason
have children tend to be automatically
almost universally
pitied and are assumed to have been
denied the chance to have offspring
by biology that one might freely choose
not to have children and yet be
reasonably content with one's choice
that remains one of the most disturbing
and
unfathomed of all modern positions
the basic dynamics of whether or not to
have children follow
the very same pattern that we see across
a range
of other so-called great choices in
emotional life
whether or not to get married whether or
not to stay
faithful whether to follow the path of
reason
or the cause of the heart we observe
a very strong desire to try to identify
the right choice
accompanied by a frighteningly utopian
belief that once this choice has been
located
we're going to be able to flourish and
find complete
peace and happiness but the reality
is of course very different much darker
but also more interesting the large
dilemmas of emotional life
have no answer in the sense of a
response that doesn't somewhere along
the line
entail a great loss and an element of
extraordinary sacrifice
whatever we choose will in a sense be a
bit
wrong and leave us regretting some
features of the choices
we didn't make there is no such thing as
a cost-free choice
a line of argument which continues oddly
to create surprise
in contemporary life making a good
choice
simply involves focusing on what variety
of suffering
we're best suited to rather than aiming
with some sort of utopian zeal
to try to avoid grief and regret
altogether
consider for example the varieties of
suffering that are on offer
on both sides of the faithful unfaithful
ledger both options will at moments be
very miserable so when weighing up how
to lead our lives
we should work on knowing as much as
possible about our specific taste
in misery let's look at a table monogamy
the misery well a sense of confinement
a correct impression that life is
elsewhere irritability
narrow horizons sexual abandonment
what about on the other side multiple
partners
what will be the misery there there'll
be chaos angry exes
loneliness long term damaged children
guilt
the very same kind of trade-offs exist
over the question
of children no honest experience of
parenting
is complete without an intermittent very
strong impression
that in some ways children are both the
meaning of one's life
and the cause of the ruin of one's life
on the one hand children the misery
disappointment with oneself as a parent
disappointment with how they turn out
guilt exhaustion lost opportunity
a sense of perpetuating human suffering
the house
sticky everywhere what about with no
children
what's the misery there society's
constant message
that one's missed out loneliness and
boredom
a lack of constant distraction and calls
on one's time
and a sentimental longing for comfort of
children
by the time one reaches the nursing home
the insight that all choices are in a
sense a bit
hellish was best expressed by the early
19th century danish
existential philosopher soren kikegaard
who summed up our options in a playful
but bleakly realistic and exasperated
outburst in his masterpiece either or
marry and you will regret it don't marry
you will also regret it
marry or don't marry you will regret it
either way
laugh at the world's foolishness you'll
regret it weep over it
you'll regret that too laugh at the
world's foolishness or weep over it
you'll regret both
believe a woman you'll regret it believe
her not
you'll also regret it hang yourself
you'll regret it don't hang yourself
you'll regret that too hang yourself or
don't hang yourself you'll regret it
either way
whether you hang yourself or don't hang
yourself you'll regret both
this gentleman is the essence of all
philosophy
we deserve pity as does everyone else
we're going to make disastrous decisions
we'll form mistaken relationships
we'll embark on misguided careers we'll
invest our savings foolishly we'll spend
years on friendships with unreliable
idiots
and we'll get it mostly wrong around
children
but we can be consoled by a bitter truth
there
aren't painless options because the
conditions of existence are
intrinsically
rather than accidentally frustrating we
can't get through the tunnel of life
without a mauling
for those of us contemplating whether or
not to have children
the message is dark but consoling in its
bleakness
you will be at points very unhappy
whatever you choose
with either option you will feel that
you've ruined
your life and you'll be correct we don't
need to add to our misery
by insisting that there would have been
another better
cost-free way there is curiously
relief to be found in the knowledge of
the inevitability of suffering
it is in the end never darkness that
dooms us
but the wrong sort of hope in that most
cruel
of fantasies the right choice
the joys and sorrows of parenting
promises us a gentle way of staying calm
around one of the most
arduous yet deeply fulfilling jobs in
the world
you